what's about my spy okay because some
movie you're promoting it's coming out
it's coming out the day before my
birthday
domestically domestically and then if
you want to see it in another country
you have to wait till the day after my
birthday because everybody knows my
birthday Oh Conan no it's coming out
around the world on Friday the 3rd March
Friday the 13th yeah this week yeah
and then and then a day after your
birthday in America ok I just want you
you feel like every day is your birthday
I just wanted to make your movie release
about my birthday it's already
incredibly complicated you worked with
David Bautista just randomly making
noises I love it clearly a Bautista fan
from working with Dave Bautista yeah
he's fine
yeah he's fun like I'm not what did you
see he was he came to a Comic Con show I
believe yeah Julie remembers all a blank
to me I've been high for years this
guy's big he's a former WWE star I mean
you know he's huge
I watched him eat an entire chicken for
lunch once the whole chicken
weight with the bones and everything I
don't know yeah he's huge and they've
gotta like you know whatever they put
into their body is so specific to keep
the Machine going and one time I ran
into him at a sushi restaurant and he
was like oh my god I'm so glad I don't
live near the sushi restaurant cuz I be
here all the time and I was like what's
wrong with that cuz I for me sushi is
healthy yeah but I guess it's not if
you're a bodybuilder cuz of the rice
yeah can you imagine well
jeez I know what it's like to constantly
craft your body to make sacrifices what
are you laughing for
at the joke I had in my head from years
ago we have a clip from from my spy oh
my god I think this is with you and
booties we get to see a little bit of
your your your energy how it's different
you guys got different energy you know
this was actually this role is meant for
a man and then I convinced them that
even these tits could do the part
my spy god I can't take this
I know the tension you can touch a
patient in the excitement you couldn't
get it dicta to the drone why pretty
quickly know the boredom ah yeah I know
so many layers ha hey as you want to say
I'm real excited to be learning from you
oh I'm not teaching you anything
oh it's more of a mentor-mentee
relationship we have zero relationship
yet but we're building toward something
pretty great I can just feel it you'll
share your harrowing experiences in the
field and I'll show you do not touch
okay that was awesome
[Applause]
I'm gonna see that movie I see that
movie in Hong Kong with your kids yeah
that's what's kind of fun want the cat
here all the time well then your kids
can be fan of me yeah just so you know
this morning actually because when I was
doing Comic Con with you they gave me
all the Conan dolls yep so I have Conan
Conan bobble head popped off yeah just
as Jon Snow and penny wise and she plays
with them all the time you never know
where she picked it up this morning and
feels like calling it calling it yeah
that's good they must learn young my spy
is gonna be in theaters this is uh
domestically yeah the day the day before
my birthday April 17 delighted you're
one of our favorite people Kristen
Schaal